oh
xbox one what a rocky six years it's
been but along the way it's become its
truest
bestest self and now with a new console
on the way with a
sort of newish name we take a look back
at the 37 most
memorable moments of the xbox one's
journey from
zero to one to x
yeah you can watch tv on your xbox one
you can watch movies on your xbox one
you can watch tv
on your xbox one you can skype with your
buds on xbox one
you can watch tv on your xbox one
watching tv tv tv tv on xbox will
immerse you
you couldn't play used games on xbox one
this is how you share your games on ps4
thanks you can play used games on xbox
one
you always have to be online with xbox
one you
don't always need to be online with xbox
one the console is 499 dollars with
connect required
the console is 399. with no connect
requirement
don matrick fortunately we have a
product for people who aren't able to
get
some form of connectivity it's called
xbox 360. right
phil spencer or as i like to say
xbox daddy x
backwards compatible with 360 games
backwards compatible with the original
xbox games
xbox game pass how great
xbox game pass is did i mention
xbox game pass it's good
id at xbox giving a platform to
independent developers
after years of e3 teases crackdown 3
came out
but sadly scalebound got canned the
slimmer xbox one
s with hdr support and 4k blu-ray player
the beefier xbox one x that plays games
in 4k the all digital xbox one
sad edition the elite controller for pro
players the elite controller series 2
for pro
players the adaptive controller for all
players
cross played with nintendo cross play
with sony
acquiring minecraft but letting it be on
other consoles helping to create ori
and cuphead and then releasing it on
other consoles
thanks xbox more halo more gears
more forza sunset overdrive and then
that game that remedy made before
control
over the uh that freeze that mr freeze
guy from x-men
yeah that one studio acquisitions lots
and lots of studio acquisitions
what were your most memorable moments
from the xbox one
let us know in the comments below and
with that any predictions you have for
the xbox series x
maybe things they'll launch with and
take away or things that they'll
add anything's possible anyways thank
you so much for watching
xbox off
you